voir je me réveille le matin avec les
mains très va enfler les pieds très
enflée j'ai arrêté de transpirer et je
n'ai plus transpiré pendant dix ans 2007
julie s'est fait poser des implants
mammaires de silicone rapidement les
symptômes se sont multipliées problèmes
gastro intestinaux en général diagnostic
d'ars en 2014 et j'étais épuisée
complètement pendant dix ans les
médecins de julie ont été perplexe
le fait d'être une femme dans la
quarantaine et tu as ouvert
l'explication fourre tout le déclic se
fait quand julie découvre un groupe
facebook consacré à la maladie des
implants mammaires
ça a été une révélation j'ai fais en mon
dieu c'est obligé cette maladie n'est
pas reconnue par le corps médical
ça fait plus de 15 ans 18 ans que le
dossier a été fermé
le président de l'association des
spécialistes en chirurgie plastique et
esthétique du québec n'y crois pas
pourquoi on n'en parle plus peut-être à
cause d'un effet de somatisation de
masse qui est un effet qui connut tous
les médecins n'ont pas la même théorie
de silicone comme liq mt au line up and
down actifs itunes store le rhumatologue
janwillem cohen terre verte a fait des
études qui démontrent que les symptômes
ressentis par certaines femmes
disparaissent
lorsqu'elles font enlever leurs implants
richer
julie a fait enlever ses implants dans
les 48 premières heures mon symptômes
majeurs à moi qui étais la sensation de
brûlure en interne la soif intense c'est
disparu complètement le débat sur la
sécurité des implants mammaires dure
depuis trente ans en 2006 santé canada a
exigé que les manufacturiers
entreprennent des études de dix ans sur
des dizaines de milliers de femmes pour
documenter les effets à long terme de
leurs produits
ces études n'ont jamais été terminée
santé canada n'a pas sévi contre les
manufacturiers
elle estime aujourd'hui qu'ils ont
respecté les exigences dans la mesure du
possible ici madeleine roy radio canada
montréal